Thumbs up means...
well, thumbs up, right?
But it's not always been that way.
In the Roman era, a thumbs up
meant death for a gladiator.
If the gladiator was to be spared,
the referee would press the thumb
to the top of the fist.
If he flicked it up, it was bad news.
There's a common misconception that
a thumbs down meant death back then.
It's thought to have stemmed from
this painting by Jean-Léon Gérôme
in 1872,
which shows a colosseum crowd
with arms outstretched
and thumbs pointing to the ground.
He got it wrong.
It's though the positive meaning
of thumbs up
started with English archers
in the Middle Ages.
A fist with thumb up measured the
correct brace height of the longbow,
so the gesture came to mean
"All is well. Ready for battle."
Another origin of the gesture comes
from merchants in Medieval times.
They would seal a deal
by licking their thumbs
and pressing them together,
so a thumbs up came to mean
"done deal".
Allied fighter pilots
in World War Two
used the gesture to indicate
"chocks away"
when they were ready for take-off,
and it's thought that American GIs
spread the gesture throughout Europe.
Even today, Italians call it...
Hitchhikers around the world hope to
"thumb a lift" from passing traffic,
but watch out in Greece, Sardinia
and the Middle East,
where a thumbs up sign is an insult
and is more likely to get you
into trouble than the next town.
When a scuba diver gives a thumbs up,
it means it's time to swim
back to the surface.
This signal has been known
to confuse beginners.
A wiggled thumbs up means the
number 10 in American sign language,
while a flat palm under a thumbs up
is the sign for "help."
In the 1990s, influential US
movie reviewers Siskal and Ebert,
used a thumbs up or thumbs down
rating system on their TV show.
They even trademarked
the phrase "two thumbs up".
Now, thumbs up and thumbs down signs
are everywhere on the internet.
Hoping for your approval.
Or otherwise.